You might be familiar with Wine, but are you familiar with Twine?
It emulates OS2 binaries, the same way that Wine can emulate Windows binary.
It's named such to continue the fine tradition of programmers producing good code and bad
product names.
And it comes from the one, the only, Ryan C. Gordon, aka Ikyulus, so you know it actually
might be a bit legitimate.
He just posted this to his patrons on his Patreon page.
And Wes, good news, they've got Unreal Tournament.
Oh boy!
Of all the things, right?
That's what he goes with.
But he's pretty fired up about it.
He actually says this is a big deal.
And Ryan does have quite a bit of experience porting games and 3D applications over to
the Linux desktop.
And you know, I gotta be honest, this does speak to me a little bit at a deep nerd level.
Not because I'm planning to use OS2 for anything, but in a way like you hate to see this stuff
die.
And when it's all digital, like we have the means to preserve this stuff, and games and
whatnot are art.
That is definitely true.
Even if you don't care about any of that, it's kind of just a fascinating read.
He dives into a bunch of details about the progress he's made so far, why it's difficult,
and why it might not be that difficult overall.
Yeah, so I expect any week now, Popeye will be taking the Twine challenge and running
everything on his desktop through an OS2 emulator.
Hang on.
Wait, what?
OS2?
Yeah.
It's an OS2 emulator.
OS2.
Yeah.
You want to take the challenge, Popeye?
I can't get my head around this.
Wimpy was more of an OS2 guy than I was.
Yeah, I've got Arkanoa on my ThinkPads.
You were a big OS2 fan, eh Wimpy?
Well what do you say?
There you go, Wimpy.
You take the challenge.
You take it.
I'll give it a go.
I switched from OS2 to Linux.
There you go.
And now you can switch back.
This is Linux Unplugged, episode 237 for February 20th, 2018.
Welcome to Linux Unplugged, your weekly Linux talk show this week that's so packed with
goodness.
Well, we're going to give you an extra side.
My name is Chris.
My name is Wes.
It's going to be a side of announcement.
We'll tell you more about that in just a little bit, but first this week we'll cover some
community news.
The good folks over at KDE just got a surprise donation from the Pineapple Fund.
We'll tell you about that.
Our friends over at Canonical want to know a little bit more about how your computer
set up, so we'll talk directly to the horse's mouth about that.
I do love the horse's mouth.
I always think of Mr. Ed.
That's right.
With the peanut butter.
So tasty.
And then later on, our good friends over at Elementary OS and System76 working on Pop
OS are doing something that I think a lot of you are going to agree with, the turning
on disk encryption by default.
But this isn't a simple implementation, and there's a lot of user challenges to work through
and edge cases that have to be thought through.
So we'll talk to them about turning on disk encryption by default when you install Elementary
OS or Pop OS in the near future.
Gnome's got a new tool to check on your system.
A big bogus Linux vulnerability is getting all of the attention this week.
OpenStreetMaps has woes, and then we're going to wrap it all up with that side.
It's going to be a tasty side.
Maybe a berry flavor.
It's an announcement here at the network.
Something big on the build up to scale is coming back to Jupiter Broadcasting.
You got to stay tuned.
You got to listen to find out that.
You know it.
You know the drill, Wes.
You know the drill.
So Wes, before we go any further, it is our duty to bring in that virtual log.
Time appropriate greetings, Bumble Room.
What's up?
Hello.
How are you?
All right.
So how many of you are using the MumbleSnap today?
Just say I.
I.
Sure.
Whoa.
Impressive.
Dude, all of a sudden I'm having FOMO.
I'm just feeling like I should be catching up.
Wow.
All right.
We'll talk about production testing.
We're going to put it through its paces this week.
All right.
Well, let's start with a little bit of good news.
The KDE project is extremely pleased to announce that they have received 200,000 U.S. Greenback
donations from the Pineapple Fund.
Now, they go on to say that they're going to use these funds to further their cause
to make free software accessible to everyone on all platforms, which is good because I
was pretty convinced until they made that statement that they were going to use that
money to fund proprietary software, so I'm pretty glad they made that clarification.
Close call.
Yeah.
The money is going to help them realize their vision of creating a world in which everyone
has control over their digital life and enjoys freedom and privacy.
Well, apparently they're going to buy out Apple and Google.
I think this is great.
The Pineapple Fund says that KDE is a necessary community project which just has a general
benefit to the public and advances the use of free software on all platforms, so that's
why they were all in.
Two hundred thousand dollars.
The Pineapple Fund has been busy recently contributing money.
I don't know a lot about the Pineapple Fund, but I need to do some more digging.
I did a little bit of reading, so I have a rough idea, but is anybody kind of familiar
with Pineapple Fund before I run my mouth about it?
Anybody want to save me and just eloquently describe in a few short, beautiful sentences?
Eloquently.
What do you think, producer Michael?
What do you think?
You got a shot?
Well, I mean, it's just like it's a Bitcoin-based philanthropist basically.
Right, and when it came to the Free Software Foundation, they actually donated Bitcoin
to the Free Software Foundation.
OpenBSD is one of the beneficiaries.
But in this case, for KD, I believe they donated cash.
They converted it to cash.
Cash.
Yeah.
Yeah, pretty interesting.
Pretty interesting.
So you can find it all out.
They have raised fifty-three million dollars and donated to fifty-eight different charities
so far.
I like that.
I think that's pretty cool.
I think that's a great use of cryptocurrency, too, you know what I mean?
And if you donate now and then they can use those funds down the road, well, today as
we record, Bitcoin is back up to $11,000, probably because of manipulation via Popey's
huge wealth.
Ugh.
That guy.
I know.
But, you know, it's going to a good cause.
Now you can feel good about that and not just feel more poor.
Yeah, exactly.
Thank you.
Thanks to Popey, really.
I think that might be Mr. Dustin Kirkland you hear there coming in a bit.
So let's talk to Dustin and Will Cook.
They're both joining us from Canonical, and you may have heard of an email that Will sent
out to the mailing list recently for the Ubuntu development in which he says that they're
looking at how to focus future resources around engineering and realized, you know, we could
use some information, some data, if you will, like what version of Ubuntu people are installing,
if they have a network connection, the type of CPU that they have, how much RAM, how did
they lay out their disks, what packages did they install, what GPU do they have, who built
their computer, these kinds of things that they don't actually currently collect.
But whenever you start talking about collecting additional data from users, it causes quite
a bit of reaction.
So I thought, instead of us just rampant speculation style here on the old show.
Oh, but that was going to be so much fun.
Dude, I'm happy to do it.
Maybe we'll just save that later.
But first, we'll get the information from Dustin and Will because they're in this thread.
And this email came from Will Cook.
So guys, welcome to the show.
And Will, why don't we start with you and kind of let's hear your version of what you
guys are proposing.
Sure.
So I mean, as you said, data-driven development.
This is what we're all about.
We need to know where we should be focusing our efforts, what things people like, what
things people use, and they should get the lion's share of our engineering efforts so
that we can fix the parts that are most important to those people.
When I first saw this, I had a couple of different reactions.
My first reaction was, oh, people aren't going to like this.
But my second reaction is, you weren't collecting this already?
You're not already collecting this information?
That seems like information that would have been collected from day one.
Well, yeah.
So from day one, we've always had an app port running, which is the thing that pops up and
says something went wrong.
Would you like to report an error about it?
That's always been there.
PopCon was there for a little while.
PopCon's been in Debian since forever.
But the raw data about what sort of hardware that we're running on, yeah, we haven't ever
gathered that.
So the thing that you're also suggesting, well, actually, I have a follow-up question
to that.
The one metric I think that's probably getting the most strong reaction would be location
information.
What kind of specific location information would you be collecting?
We talked about this internally before we sent the email.
We decided that it would be useful to everybody to know where people are in the world.
You know, if we find out that 90% of our users are based in India, let's say, then we need
to be focusing on the translations for India.
If we find out that everybody is in the US, then we need to be making sure that the English
translations are up to date.
We're not gathering IP address information.
The location will be the location that the user chooses at login.
So there's no sort of nefarious snooping on where we think you are.
This is purely you tell us you're in this country.
We take that on face value and that's what we record.
And so it's not tracked to like a specific user and location.
So you wouldn't necessarily get Chris F. in Arlington, Washington when you look back at
the metrics?
No, it's like purely country level, literally top level country level information.
Okay.
And then the other thing, so you mentioned it really in there quickly as PopCon.
PopCon is a tool, if I'm correct, that sort of monitoring the user's packages that they
install to give you guys over a canonical and aggregate overview of the most popular
packages.
The idea there, I suppose, would be, well, if we have an idea of what the most popular
packages are, then we know where to dedicate patch time, backporting time, resource development
time, integration time.
Is that what PopCon is about?
Exactly.
And we have the archives and people hit the archives in order to get packages.
But let's say that we could look at the web logs on those servers, which we don't.
But if we could do, we could see that people were installing a specific package.
A lot of people are installing a specific package.
That doesn't tell us whether they install it once and then uninstall it or they install
it and they use it every day or they install it and they use it once a year.
That's the sort of information that PopCon gives us, and with that information, we can
look at promoting packages that are in universe, which is the lowest level of support that
we offer, up to main, which is something that our security team get involved in.
So if everybody's installing a specific package from universe, they're using it every day,
then we can look at promoting that to main and then the security team and whoever it
is that's maintaining that package will be able to spend a lot more time making sure
that security bugs are fixed, making sure that the latest versions are packaged, keeping
that update for everybody.
So yeah, that's extremely useful information for us and it's extremely beneficial to our
users.
So I think I have a couple of questions specifically for Dustin, but Will, one of my kind of bigger
picture questions I have for you is the flip side of this is you've also stated that you
plan to make the data public.
Wouldn't that also mean that you plan to reveal exactly, roughly, pretty damn close how many
Ubuntu installations there are, how many people are using Dell laptops versus an entryware
laptop?
Like isn't this going to result in a lot of speculation being answered?
Because then you'll have real numbers.
People have like, well, Ubuntu has X amount of users and there's never really been a big
public number released about that.
Will I'll jump in here actually at this point, yeah, I think that's exactly right and everything
that we've put out so far has been our best guess interpolation on roughly how many users
have downloaded the ISO from the Ubuntu.com mirror, not the mirror run by your local university
because obviously we can't count package updates or ISO downloads from mirrors, for instance.
So in a way, yes, there will be a lot more information available about the general usage
of Ubuntu, how and where.
I actually hope that there's some interesting conclusions that can be drawn by people outside
of Canonical.
I often look at the stats that are published by Docker Hub.
If you go to, you hit Docker's API, you can see pulls of the Ubuntu image or the CentOS
image or the Debian image or the Mongo or the MySQL image, and I think part of that
is obviously those are statistics that were anonymously gathered by your usage of the
Docker binary fetching an image from Docker Hub, but the fact that that information is
also available for others to consume and graph and plot and interpolate is I think that's
part of the important social exchange.
That is an interesting idea.
So I want to ask you a couple of specifics about that really.
So what you're really talking about is essentially making all this data public and then making
JSON feeds or some sort of queryable feed available so people can programmatically generate
graphs.
That brings me to the infrastructure question.
All of this I'm on board with and in fact, like I said, it kind of seems like it should
have been done from day one.
The part that I take pause with is the backend implementation of storing this data and verifying
that it is being abstracted away from user identifiable information.
How is that being put together?
Because it seems like we're late in the 1804 game right now for that to be built, but I'm
only looking at it from the outside.
Sure.
So that backend infrastructure is not yet implemented.
In fact, right now we put this out on the Ubuntu Devel list that will post it to the
Ubuntu Devel list, which is where we discuss proposals such as this.
And if we started transmitting that information and just sent it to a dev null, nothing to
catch it just yet, that would be okay in that eventually we will have that infrastructure
in place and set up.
Of course, we're based in Europe and have lots of users in Europe, and everybody knows
the GDPR requirements come into play this year.
And so Canonical as a company, as a business, we're under the regulation of the EU and we're
taking this very seriously.
So there should be every bit of confidence here that this data will be dealt with as
anonymously as possible, and not just because we feel that we owe that to the free and open
source community, but also because it's EU law, frankly, at this point.
Yeah, okay.
I mean, that, yeah, I completely forgot about the new rules coming into place and that does
make sense.
So my question then, I guess I go from that to, and I'm not sure if this is maybe a will
question or a Dustin question, but let's assume this all gets worked out, stuff gets built
in, the option in the installer is there where people can uncheck it.
How does it affect distributions that are based on Ubuntu that are maybe using the Ubiquity
installer?
Sure.
So I will throw a spotlight on that first point.
This will be as easy to disable on any machine as clicking one box to uncheck and that disables
all diagnostic information.
So what we'll describe, there's basically three sets of information.
One is a set of pretty generic statistics about a machine, how many disks, how many
network cards, what sort of CPU.
What that enables us to do is to ensure that the Ubuntu experience is optimized for the
sort of moving target of what does the system hardware that Ubuntu is running on generally
look like, where are the outliers, where's the sort of center of gravity.
That bit of information is more or less a one shot, here's the hardware profile.
Can we underscore that for a second because that was something that wasn't totally clear
to me but because the way it's sort of worded in the email to the mailing list is it sort
of sounds like when I think of user collection metrics, I think of Windows 10 telemetry and
I think of almost constantly sending as I use my computer, sending back information
but with the exception of package installations, it's essentially a one shot data collection.
Is that accurate?
That's right.
So where'd this all come from was we were looking at the Ubuntu installer and we were
debating as to whether some of the installation options made sense anymore.
There was a checkbox at the very beginning which says automatically download updates
while installing, which I always check because sure, when I'm done installing, I want to
have all the updates and so I asked the team, hey, do people check that box or not?
I'm curious, can we just get rid of that box and automatically download updates while installing
them?
And as it turns out, we don't know.
We don't know how many people check the box that says install the MP3, yes, I want MP3s
to work on my Ubuntu machine.
We actually don't know how many people opt to encrypt their hard disk.
I'm really keen to hear from the elementary OS guys about their disk encryption plans
and sort of a place where I geek out about.
We didn't actually know and at that point, we started looking at just the installer and
being able to know what does the average Ubuntu user select as their base set of installation
options?
Are there some options we could just get rid of because they just don't make sense anymore?
And in doing so, we combined that effort with another set of questions we had around what
desktop apps are installed on the most Ubuntu machines as well as what are the buggiest
apps in the Ubuntu archive?
And we realized all of this really comes together in a general send diagnostics or don't option
that we see in every operating system, be it Windows or Android or Mac.
We'd like to do that tastefully and we will do that tastefully.
And I think the fact that we're offering to share that information publicly hopefully
makes it valuable to the average Ubuntu user.
The average Ubuntu user will see a better Ubuntu experience.
Sure.
It just clearly gives you a better path to follow when you can see, oh, look at everybody
is installing Thunderbird.
It's just Thunderbird is getting removed from almost every system.
And I go back to something we covered this week in Linux Action News is 1804 is going
to feature a minimal install option which removes like 80 packages including Rhythmbox
and Thunderbird and a few others that I don't generally use.
And of course Canonical would have no way of knowing if anybody is using that unless
they turn something like this on.
And you can see what options people are doing during installation.
But Dustin, I just want to underscore and make it super crazy clear for everybody listening
because I think this is a really important point.
The only ongoing data collection if somebody checks this box is if an app crashes and it
will submit the crash in the background now.
That's right.
If package states change and then those statistics will get submitted, that's the only ongoing
collection.
That's right.
So when a package crashes, AppOrt catches that crash and would send Canonical a crash
report.
And Will can talk about how we've used that, how that has helped identify some pretty major
breakages in Ubuntu and we've been able to stave that off early.
People who enable the proposed repository will start catching those packages if you
chose.
And then we cannot roll out that buggy fix to the masses of millions of Ubuntu users.
So yes, that would be ongoing.
The other one would be a periodic, and I don't know what the period is, I don't know if it's
daily or weekly, but think on the order of daily or weekly, anonymous submission of the
packages installed on the system.
So that's PopCon.
PopCon is what we're going to use, which has been in Debian for ages.
We've been using PopCon, but we suspect that the number of users who go out of their way
to enable PopCon on Ubuntu is probably less than 5%.
And so it's not very representative.
And you know who does enable it?
Geeks, like you and me.
Probably not the Ubuntu user at large who's never heard of PopCon.
So our statistical bias there is quite high.
So what do you know, Vim and Emacs are super high on the PopCon statistics list, meanwhile
VLC is relatively low.
Who would have thought?
Yeah.
Hmm.
So to your point about using that data to catch stuff, Will, is that sort of, to Will
here, is that sort of, Dustin being polite and saying this is one of the reasons why
we're not shipping Whalen in 1804 is because of this data we've collected with the app
crashes?
Yeah, absolutely.
If you go to errors.ubuntu.com, then you can see the sort of crash reports that we're getting
in there.
And you know, at the top of that list are the buggiest applications.
And that is what we look at every day.
And those are the bugs that we focus our efforts on.
So yeah, absolutely.
This is invaluable information for our team.
Look at that big huge jump right there.
Oh, Wayland.
That's great.
Yeah, errors.
I don't think I've ever actually looked at the graph there at errors.ubuntu.com.
That is pretty cool.
So what's next?
This is exactly errors.ubuntu.com is exactly the sort of information that we make public,
that we collect and we make public.
And I think this is, you know, we're not hiding what we're doing with this information.
We're trying to make Ubuntu better by studying graphs like this.
So this is obviously pretty important to get into 1804 because that's the next big one
that people are going to be using for five years.
So what's the next functional step?
You guys are collecting feedback, do you start actually like building out the code on the
client side?
Do you start looking at mocking up ways for users to possibly disable this after install?
Yeah, the mockups are public in that same thread that Will started on Ubuntu Devel.
Canonical's lead UI UX designer, Matthew Paul Thomas, replied with a publicly visible Google
doc, which is the design doc for the overall Ubuntu installer.
It's 40 or 50 pages long.
But if you control F, search in there for diagnostics, you'll land somewhere in the
middle of that document.
You can see the rough mockups from our UI UX team as to what the wording will look like,
where it will fit into the flow of installing Ubuntu, and how it's enabled and disabled.
So I guess I just, I have, well, one piece of advice, if I could for a moment, if I could
be so brave, is to make it clear that if there's some way to keep it short, but make it clear
that it's not this crazy ongoing metric collection, I think that's what people are worried about.
But the question, I guess, that I think of from an end user perspective is, so say I
go buy a Dell Sputnik XPS 13, I would assume that Dell is probably going to turn this on
by default.
And I don't go through that installation process as an OEM customer.
What is going to be my opt out option in that scenario?
And how likely is that feature to ship?
Will, you want to talk a little bit about how this will be enabled, disabled after the
fact in the system center?
Sure, sure.
So yeah, you go to the GNOME control center, GNOME settings, and in there, there's a privacy
tab or option down the left hand side.
And in there are all the usual privacy stuff which exists today, and there will be some
extra buttons in there.
We're still working through the designs, as Dustin said, where we're working with design
on how granular we get at that point.
Do we allow people to individually toggle the Apple reporting and the popcorn results?
Or is that going to be confusing to the average Joe, and it should just be on or off?
These are decisions which need to be made.
But those settings will exist, they will exist on day one, and they'll be there to switch
on and off as you choose.
Right.
So the Apple-based approach would be the binary, send statistics or not, keep it simple.
Just one thing, the slightly more Linux approach would be, well, let's actually dissect that.
Would you like to send crash reports, yes or no?
Would you like to send package information, yes or no?
Would you like to send hardware information, yes or no?
So I think we're going to work through that.
But as I said, we're soliciting feedback, and we're keen to hear from your users, your
listeners as well.
What's the most constructive way for them to get involved if they're fired up about
this, and they want to constructively contribute?
So let's point them to the Launchpad bug tracker.
Okay.
I do have one question.
Yeah, go ahead, go ahead.
So is there anything being done for de-averaging?
I just think about my personal use case, where I install Linux, and a lot of times it gets
to be Ubuntu, in a lot of old machines, that it's not the primary driver.
And of course, that will definitely skew the statistics saying, hey, we have a bunch of
old machines.
Yeah, people firing things up to try it out, things like that.
I think that's super important information, actually.
I think it'll all come out as we start treating this data, millions of records, potentially.
I think it's super interesting if there are still people using Ubuntu and expect Ubuntu
to run on an ancient Dell netbook or something like that.
I think that's important.
The data will show 32-bit lives!
What I really wanted to know is if you can disclose what type of strategy and if that
information will also be released.
Because de-averaging is definitely one of the hardest things to do properly when you
have large data sets.
So I'm interested to hear that side, because for me, as a developer, I can go into that
list of information you're releasing, and I would be able to say, oh, so people are
building for these low-end computers, better not use these new fancy features.
But reality is, my target user base would still be on the fancy computer.
So the question is, to sort of pare this down, the question really is, will you publicly
be disclosing the math being used to average all this stuff out?
Sure.
I don't see why not.
I predict no fewer than five master's thesis written in 2019 based on Ubuntu.com statistics.
Five thesis and 25 conspiracies, Dustin.
So producer Michael, I want to give you the last question, then we should probably move
on, because I think producer Michael has a good one.
Yeah, I was just wondering, the data itself is interesting, and the opt-out is something
I actually think is potentially beneficial in another way that might not be considered
in some people.
But I was wondering, if you have it so that someone has to opt-out, and they check it
to opt-out, would that information be sent to Canonical as well so that people would
know how many people opt-out versus continue?
One ping only.
Yeah, that's the proposal right now, that there's one ping that says opt-out or statistics
equals false.
Once again, we throw away the IP address and the location information.
But the simple ping of this user declined is important in understanding the statistical
validity and the statistical power, and those are statistics terms, of the data set, actually.
If you don't know how big the data set is, the data is only so useful.
I agree.
Yeah, I agree.
So let's start the ridiculous outrage right now.
Canonical's even tracking me when I tell them not to track me.
There you go.
I said it first, so now you can make fun of anybody else who says it after me.
It's a spyware.
Guys, this is all fascinating.
I'm really curious to see where this goes.
Is there any other points you wanted to get out there before we move on to some of our
other news?
So I'm just curious, how much would this impact trying to get more OEMs to try to deploy Ubuntu
on their machines as an option?
Hmm, well we know until we see the data, that's really the thing.
Potentially it has a lot of potential because they actually would have data.
I've been around Canonical for over 10 years now, and in the early days it was trying to
convince Dell and Lenovo and others to take a chance on this crazy open source Linux distribution
at a time when Windows and Mac sort of dominated the market.
There was no Chrome OS, there was no Android, and it was super difficult to show the size
of the free and open source community.
I think if nothing else, even non-Ubuntu users hopefully can understand and appreciate that
this sort of information will help all open source projects make their case that, hey,
we do deserve, we, the open source community, do deserve a seat at the table at any OEM,
ODM discussion, and hardware enablement from your latest Bluetooth and Wi-Fi and graphics
adapter just working out of the box with Linux.
All of that has to happen upstream.
Someone has to pay for that development.
Some product manager somewhere has to make the case that there's enough Linux users out
there to make this justified exactly.
Yeah, that could be a huge contribution if you think about it.
That could really be a massive amount of data because one of the things that seems to be
definitely true just from an observational standpoint is nothing puts the stress on a
project like Ubuntu shipping it by default.
Once it starts, I mean, you can have, with all respect to the projects like Fedora and
others that will ship Wayland and ship the GNOME desktop for years and do a really good
job of getting that shipping, but there's nothing like Ubuntu shipping something by
default because it puts a whole nother category of stress on something.
And it's way more eyes, it's way more different flavors of users.
It's a totally different world.
And so if we could start to, as the community, get data from this huge distribution, massively
beneficial, even if you're not using Ubuntu.
And the fact that you guys are gonna make it clear and easy to uncheck the box, I just
really, I can't find anything to be super upset about this.
And I would love to.
I love me a good ramp.
It'd be a great story.
Yeah.
It sounds pretty solid.
So guys, thanks for coming on here.
Will and Dustin.
I really appreciate hearing it from you directly.
Thank you very much.
And I'll be keeping an eye on how this all goes and see what goes, where things, where
things develop.
What do you think, Wes?
Yeah.
I think you're absolutely right and that we have this wonderful open source ecosystem.
And so it seems like there will only benefit any number of different projects.
It is the era of data and it's another way to contribute now.
Yeah.
It is data.
And if it can be done in a tasteful way that doesn't like …
Up front and …
I like that the location stuff is country level too.
That makes me feel way better about it.
I like it.
All right.
Well, we'll let you guys know though.
It'll be something we look at in our 1804 review.
So we'll know when it ships, whatever state it does ship.
Let's keep going though.
We have so much more to get into.
I wanna take a moment and thank Ting for sponsoring the program here.
Ting is pay for what you use mobile, a fair price for how much you talk, text and data
you use with nationwide coverage, no contracts, no sneaky agreements, anything weird like
that in there.
It's just simple pay for what you use.
I think I pay somewhere around 40 bucks, usually just below that for three lines.
Average Ting bill is $23 per phone.
I know.
And you know what, Wes?
It's their birthday.
Is it?
It's happy birthday, Ting.
I know.
And to celebrate, they're giving away shirts because you get presents for Ting's birthday.
First 100 Ting customers.
I gotta get them.
That is.
I actually should ask Kyra who did their swag for that, because that is legit.
And I wouldn't mind getting that same person to do some swag for us.
Koda Radio?
Damn near 300 episodes.
I gotta get some good...
Whoa!
I gotta...
That's some legit swag.
So the first 100 customers at Ting get that.
I don't think I'm in the first 100, but I've been there for almost four years, so I gotta
be in the range.
I don't know.
I wish I could be a Ting hipster.
Anyways, they're still giving away some, so maybe I could still get one and you can too.
If you go to the Ting blog, but start, do us a favor, start by going to linux.ting.com.
That'll take $25 off a device or $25 in credit if you bring a device.
They've got a great control panel, fantastic customer service, and tons of devices to choose
from.
And really, the best customer support ever, linux.ting.com.
Go follow them on the Twitters, too.
That's how I found out about their t-shirt giveaway, their Ting FTW on the Twitter, linux.ting.com.
And a big thanks to Ting for sponsoring the Unplugged program.
Boom-da-boom, boom-da-boom, boom-da-boom.
I like the drums there, Wes.
You knew where I was going.
I sure do.
Wes was air drumming while I did that.
Dude, that's almost worth putting a camera on you just for that.
All right, well, so you heard Dustin mention it there, and I teased it in the intro.
The Crazy Cats over at Pop!
OS in elementary got together and decided, you know what we need to do?
We need to collaborate on making it possible to ship encryption turned on by default on
future System76 machines running Pop!
OS and elementary OS installs.
So to tell us about this crazy work is Cassidy and Dan from elementary OS and slash System76
in Cassidy's case to tell us all about this.
So guys, where do you think we should start?
Cassy, should we start with you and tell us about the work, sort of the collab work between
Pop!
OS and elementary on this here thing?
Sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
So how did that kick off?
I mean, I know you are kind of, you're kind of in a good position there being involved
in both elementary OS and working for System76 as an employee, but that didn't necessarily
mean this had to come about.
Right.
Well, obviously I'm a secret agent for elementary within System76.
It's a long play.
That's a long play, Cassy.
No.
So, um, yeah, like I've been using, I had been using elementary OS at System76 for quite
some time.
Um, and you know, anytime you can collaborate with another project, it's a good idea to
think about it.
Yeah.
Really, especially if it's something like working on an installer together, that seems
to be like a solid sort of collection of resources and efforts.
Yeah.
And so we had, we've done a little bit of collaboration in the past with like app center.
So elementary developed app center and pop OS is using it as a pop shop, which is just
a really simple front end for the, uh, repositories.
Okay.
But we decided, you know, elementary had designed this spec for an installer and we'd actually,
we'd been working on it for years.
Um, just kind of on as a back burner, like, Hey, someday when we get the resources to
do this, we should, this is what we want the experience to look like.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, and System76 when they kicked off pop OS, um, they were kind of thinking the same
thing like, Hey, we have a chance to really tailor the install experience.
You have the people's first touch of pop OS and System76, um, with an installer and they
looked at the elementary spec for our installer and they liked it.
And so we got together and hacked on it for a week.
Okay.
Fair enough.
So we did that.
Uh, I forget when the first hack fest was, but that was, it was a few months ago.
We did a first like initial hack fest, went over the spec and, uh, went over the designs
that we had already designed.
Uh, we, we updated them.
The elementary guys worked on the front end and the, uh, System76 people worked on the
backend and it, it got off to a great start.
Um, I think we have an upcoming blog post about that.
That one's not published yet.
Um, but after working on that a bit, we decided to get back together and this was last month
to continue working on it and discuss, um, kind of where we are and what we want to do
next.
Hmm.
And is that when the topic of encryption came up?
Precisely.
Yeah.
So, um, a lot of System76 customers actually require full disk encryption.
So that's, you know, high security environments, some of the strictest security, uh, requirements,
uh, they have to have their entire disk encrypted and that's something you can't really do out
of the box well today.
Um, it requires you reinstall the OS.
So what we would have is we'd have customers who were getting the OS or getting, getting
System76 hardware, then downloading the OS and then having to flashing into a flash drive,
wiping their computer, reinstalling, and then probably forgetting to install the PPA and
it's, you know, it's like the purpose of, you know, out of the box experience out of
the box.
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it was really important to System76 to have encryption out of the box cause that's
a big requirement for a lot of our customers.
Okay.
So we started thinking, you know, if we're working on this installer, we have an opportunity
to ship encryption out of the box.
And so that's what that blog post was about.
Um, and figuring out and really, you know what, when I, when I went through this, um,
what I realized Cassidy is that it is way more complicated than just checking a box
by default.
Like you have stuff in here about recovery partitions and essentially like escape hatches.
Can you talk, so what is that, what's the big, what's the big, what's the big problem
by turning this on by default?
Cause obviously if it was just checking a box, that probably would have been done five
years ago.
Right.
So yeah, the biggest, I mean, there's kind of two things.
There's the technical implications and the UX implications.
Sure.
Yeah.
Um, the, the technical implications are that you can't ship a computer that's encrypted
out of the box, uh, and have that actually be acceptable because the OEM then has the
encryption key.
Right.
And they probably generate it from some sort of standard image.
So if they have some sort of flaw in their process, it could become predictable.
I would imagine that's something to worry about too, is like you have to make sure you're
encrypting it in a way where the user owns the password.
Yeah.
And there can't be an opportunity for the OEM to get that password because then it's,
it's not as, you know, it's just useless and you have to reinstall it anyway.
How do you do that?
How do you do that when you're, when you're shipping it pre-built?
So we, uh, we started talking about this idea of a recovery partition and this is something
other OSs do.
Um, but it's where basically you have an install media as a small partition on the drive out
of the box.
Um, and this gives you, you know, if you totally screw up your system and need to reinstall,
it means you can just reboot into the restore partition and reinstall without having to
go get a flash drive or anything.
And with that comes the ability to reinstall the OS as soon as you get it.
So you're, you could still technically be reinstalling the OS when you get it, but it
removes the need to go get a flash drive and download the OS again and everything.
So with our installer, the idea is you can, when you receive the computer, you open it
up and as far as, as far as the user is concerned, it says, you know, Hey, do you want to encrypt
your drive?
And you can say, yeah, sure.
That sounds great.
And what it's actually doing under the hood is reinstalling the entire OS.
Wow.
But you don't realize it and then you reboot and you're off and you set up your user and
you're good to go.
So it's still pretty close to the old out of the box experience.
They don't have to go through all about the full installer.
They get boot started halfway through, but under the hood it's all still new.
Yeah.
And so this installer has a mode like it, so it has an OEM mode and then it must have
like a, like a, just a regular end user mode.
If I download the ISO and I installed Juno or pop OS, I get the installer that lets me
do it at the time of installation.
But then there's like, there's, there's been allowances made for the OEM to set it up.
And the settings at the OEM sets must translate through re-installation, I would assume.
Yeah.
That's the idea is that we precede as much information as we can.
So if you know, if you choose a language or if you choose, you know, any settings that
you choose get restored back when you do the re-install.
New packages, different PPAs?
I'm not sure what all that is right now.
And is this going to be available in elementary OS as well as pop OS?
Uh, hopefully, eventually.
Good man.
You don't want to say for sure, cause it's all like future stuff.
Yeah.
Our standard line is, you know, when it's ready.
When it's, I see that actually, it's literally the ending line to the blog post.
Yeah.
So the goal would be to ship it in the next version of elementary OS and pop OS.
I think in both of those cases, we both, System76 and elementary have a backup plan of shipping
ubiquity as is, if, you know, things don't get done in time.
Because I think we're both aiming to release in April or as close to that as we can.
So you know, there's that a little bit of a time crunch and you've got to figure out
if it's worth shipping an entirely new and less tested installer or shipping the old
and...
Well, to that point, there must have been, I mean, there must have been some discussion
between the teams there where you're looking at the things you need to accomplish.
And I don't, because I wasn't there, the top three on my list installer wouldn't have been
there.
So why was installer number one?
Like, what was the background to say, we really got to address this problem?
And I'm particularly interested from the pop OS perspective, because to me, it seems like
the majority of the pop OS customers are going to experience the OEM install.
They're probably using pop OS pre-installed, but the installer was still a high priority.
So do you have any background on sort of that and kind of what the goal is there?
Sure.
With pop OS, I mean, it is definitely, it's made for system 76, like first and foremost,
but we definitely want it to be usable by anybody out there.
So installing, you know, the first experience you get when you're installing is still your
first experience with system 76, if you didn't buy a computer from system 76.
So when you buy a computer, you're getting it in, you're going to the website, you're
getting the packaging, you're opening it up, you're getting the first experience of the
hardware.
So you have a good first experience there.
But when you're installing pop OS, you know, on some other machine, your first experience
is really the installation.
So we wanted to make sure that no matter how you experience system 76, it's a good first
experience.
Sure.
And if I go through that and I go, damn, that was pretty smooth, I might think, I wonder
what else they do that's smooth like that.
Right, right.
It's, you know, the whole interaction is important.
And then even with the OEM installer, or even with the OEM installation, when you get it,
you still do go through that first setup right out of the box.
So you're still actually going through part of the installer process, especially with
the full disk encryption, that was really important that you would actually have to
go through an installer process.
It can't be a user setup if you're going to fully encrypt the disk.
So encryption by default, I think everybody in our audience is going to be pretty on board
with that.
A question from Noah that sometimes folks have issues when they're updating like Nvidia
binary drivers and whatnot.
Did you run into those issues and have to sort of test through that?
I mean, we're always doing constant testing on things.
We have a QA team that does that at system 76.
But it's kind of to the point where technically it works really well.
The people who know it doesn't work for them have an option to just not encrypt right out
of the box.
Sure, right.
But I think, you know, pushing it by default, it's secure by default, like that's protecting
user data by default is what you should be doing in today's day and age.
So I think it's important to get it out there by default.
And that also helps, you know, add a whole lot more testing in after we obviously test
it at system 76, that also adds a lot of testing out there in the real world if it's shipping
by default.
Yeah, I mean, when you think about it, laptops are becoming more and more the primary machine
for a lot of people doing work.
And so that's really where the use case is to encrypt your data.
Maybe if you have a desktop that's 75 pounds and sitting on your in your home office.
I don't know.
But for a laptop, like, you know, you you're always working on on your laptop.
And especially I can imagine you have many clients, you know, that's a absolutely many
standards required.
And good on you guys.
I think people are going to really like this.
And it's pretty cool to see the collaboration there, too.
It seems like a natural fit.
I'm waiting for the day when I can buy a system 76 machine in the currency of my choice with
elementary OS pre installed.
That is going to happen.
It's going to happen.
Of course, the currency of choice will see it's always changing.
But good stuff, guys.
I'm here.
I just want to add kudos to the elementary OS guys.
That's fantastic.
I've spent a lot of my career working on disk encryption and encryption in Ubuntu.
And I applaud you for the work and development that you've done here.
I think it's fantastic.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, I agree.
And it's going to be great to get more end users banging on this for everybody.
That's the thing.
Plus, as Linux users, we love to talk about how secure our operating system is.
But a lot of times it's far behind unless you know what you're doing.
So this is a great step in that direction.
And you know what else the takeaway story is?
The big story is the 1804 installer and distros that are based on 1804 and their installers
are about to get a lot more interesting in this next release cycle.
There's new things that are coming.
Just really quickly, too, while we're talking about new things that are coming.
Did you see Gnome Usage?
Gnome Usage and Gnome 3.28, speaking of 1804, and another distro shipping Gnome 328.
There's a new app in there.
It's called Gnome Usage.
It's sort of basic at this point.
It really kind of shows you two things.
It shows you your resources and your storage.
And that's...
What else is there?
That's kind of it.
And it's current.
It's real time like what's happening right now.
It's not like historical.
User usage, memory usage, network usage, and storage usage.
It actually looks decent, though.
It's something that's actually been in work for two years, as Joey points out over at
OMG Ubuntu, and it does not replace Gnome System Monitor.
Don't worry.
Your beloved System Monitor is still there.
In fact, it's getting a couple of new features, including improved support for dark themes
in Gnome 328.
So there you go.
Even though I'm recording this on a plasma desktop, still giving you some Gnome updates,
right?
Hey, we can do that here.
We may have done the plasma challenge and found it to be...
Well, all of us except for Poppy.
Rumor has it Poppy moved off like some sort of vagabond.
Shut your filthy mouth.
No, I didn't.
Oh, really?
Oh.
I'm still using KDE Neon like a champ.
It's great.
In fact, I haven't even rebooted since I installed it.
No kidding.
I actually wouldn't have either, but we had a power outage over the weekend here at the
studio.
So a couple of my KDE machines did have to reboot.
Okay.
All right.
Well, there you go.
The rumors before the show were false.
Yeah, there's been some false gossip.
Wow.
I don't know if we've ever had...
Sorry about that.
I don't know if we've ever had a challenge stick like this before.
You know, I'll say this too.
The other day, I had my machine up for a while and I went to go resize some windows and it
was still fast.
That sounds like a small thing, but it's all it takes to make me happy is that the fact
that I can resize windows and it's not super...
Responsive to the last.
You know what?
It has been.
And I really like it.
Well, there you go.
A little update there and some new toys coming to the Gnome desktop in three, two, eight.
Lots of goodies coming down the...
Just a couple of weeks away, actually.
I was going to say, coming down the river.
Yeah, this sounds like the future, but it's basically tomorrow.
It's like a few episodes out.
Just a...
Boy, we have so much to get to.
I'm excited.
You know what else is just a few episodes out is scale.
Scale's coming up really soon too.
And then shortly after that, it's Linux Fest.
Whoa.
Where will we find the time?
You sure you don't want to jump on Lady Joops and just come down to scale, Wes?
I mean, I'll put out the couch for you.
Now that is very tempting.
You know what?
Take a little road trip in Lady Joops.
There's nothing like traveling in Joops down to California.
I'll tell you what, you know, you could keep Levi company.
I was going to say, if there's Levi involved.
All right.
Well, before we get into the rest of the community news, including that bogus Linux vulnerability,
OpenStreetMap woes, and my big announcement, let's talk about DigitalOcean, simplicity
at scale.
It's a platform you can spin up infrastructure on in seconds.
Everything is SSD based, and they just recently revamped the pricing.
And this just in from the back office here, Wes.
Big news.
Chris really blew it.
Wes was here when I got the note, which you can hear is a physical is actually so fresh
and clean.
It's a physical note.
And and I believe my exact words were, Oh, God, I am such an idiot.
That's exactly verbatim.
Yeah, I got an email here printed out for me.
If you guys go to if you're a new customer, you got to be a new DO customer.
Sorry, this is a new customer only thing.
If you go to do.co slash unplugged for 60 days, you can get $100 credit at DigitalOcean.
What?
Yeah, I usually say a $10 credit.
They update a little bit for because they've just recently rolled out a whole bunch of
new features.
They've made their pricing even more competitive.
And they have new flexible droplets at $15 a month.
You can mix and match resources the most appropriate for your application.
They have their big memory and CPU optimized droplets and of course, my favorite the three
cents an hour just got all the droplets got better.
If you if you've been listening to the show for a while and you built a machine on DigitalOcean,
go upgrade it.
You just have to shut it down.
Do the upgrade thing.
And the reason why you have to shut it down is because they'll even re expand your file
system.
I mean, like it's the full, full upgrade.
It's so great.
$100 credit though.
They've had this offer out here for a couple of weeks and I forgot to tell the audience
because I didn't read that paragraph.
So go get on it.
Get set up.
Yeah.
Experience the joy.
And now we sit around going, why is nobody taking advantage of a $100 offer?
We don't do that very often, ever.
So I'm just an idiot.
Anyway, so you go to do.co slash unplug to get the $100 credit and you can try out something
over there for whatever you want.
I mean, go build a splurge, enjoy yourself.
You want to build a GitLab?
You want to go build the next cloud instance?
You want to try out something?
Just do it.
DigitalOcean.com and they also have a ton of really good documentation.
You hear us mention the Arch Wiki all the time.
I would say only number two to the Arch Wiki, the only number two to Arch Wiki these days
is DigitalOcean's documentation.
Only because they're paying people to contribute and so that's good quality stuff and it's
really well structured and they have like a style guide and all that stuff and it makes
it really easy to read and follow.
And that's just one of the perks of being a DigitalOcean customer.
That's why Docker and Slack and Jupiter Broadcasting and many others are DigitalOcean customers.
DigitalOcean.com, go use our promo code DOUNPLUGGED or DO.CO slash unplugged and hopefully you
still have time because it was a limited time offer and I forgot to tell you guys for a
couple of weeks because I speed read.
You know how sometimes I mispronounce stuff?
Yeah, it affects all things of life, including giving you a $100 offer.
I apologize.
Go to DO.CO slash unplugged and get a $100 DigitalOcean credit.
I can't even believe I'm saying those words out loud.
$100 DigitalOcean credit.
I wish I was a new customer, except then I wouldn't have been enjoying DigitalOcean's
all the awesome things.
You've got multiple email addresses.
Come on.
All right, so let's just really quickly talk about this bogus Linux vulnerability.
It's got Steven J. Vanhoch Nicholas really fired up and it takes a lot to get him fired
up these days.
So GoSecure, a company that's trying to make a name for itself, has claimed and discovered
Chaos, a stolen backdoor rising again.
That's their title for it.
It's a pretty good name, actually, and here's sort of the dirty secret of this horrible
vulnerability called Chaos that GoSecure has discovered.
It just simply brute forces an SSH login.
So you just basically get compromised if you have a bad password.
If you've got a good password, it's not taking advantage of any zero-day exploits.
It's not using some sort of side-channel timing attack to read the memory and parse together
your password.
It's just simply using a password database.
Or just use keys.
Yeah, I know, right?
It's just in from 2006.
Once your system's already been spread wide open because you used a bad password, then
things tend to go wrong.
It opens up TCP port 8338, which is accepting raw socket connections.
And then once it has a bad password and it gets on there, if... Oh, I should mention,
it can only open up port 8338, by the way, if it has root access, because it's Linux,
which means you also have a weak root password.
So if you have a weak user password and a weak root password, then it can get on there
and cause some problems.
And it's called Chaos, and it's getting a lot of print this week.
So if you hear people talking about a new Linux vulnerability called Chaos, don't worry.
Just make sure you have a good password.
Or use keys like...
I would suggest password123, just set that as root enable, root login over SSH.
You'll be fine.
All right.
I don't want to get too down about this, but I actually kind of... I kind of want the
mumble rooms take on this, because it seems like it's a problem for anything that wants
to take on Google or Apple or what Amazon or Microsoft is doing.
And I'm talking about OpenStreetMaps.
It's a pretty great product, and I really like the way it displays information.
I kind of prefer... When I'm looking at certain areas, I was checking out Pasadena recently
trying to figure out if I could bark LadyJupes anywhere down there, and I just found the
labeling system better and more accurate.
Not accurate.
I don't know.
It's more useful, but it's missing data that it would be nice to have in certain...
Yeah.
There are some cases.
It's got some data that other things don't have, but then it's missing a bunch of... Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
One of my friends, a computer, wrote up an article about some of the problems that he
sees with OpenStreetMap, and he's a big fan of OpenStreetMap, so this isn't like a takedown
piece.
It's him being concerned about it.
And he talks about unclear usage policies, about how they sort of discourage the use
of the free map, but then if you ask for it, they'll let you, but then if you use more
than 5% of their bandwidth, they'll shut it down.
They really want you to use their data to generate your own map, and then there's things
in the back end, like the geocoder that figures out different areas and helps you search is
really bad and it's way out of date.
It expects very clear syntax, like an exact address, and you can't say things like bagel
places downtown Seattle.
And then the killer one is there's no moderation or review model, which, as you could probably
imagine for something like OpenStreetMap...
It could be difficult.
Yeah.
Introduces a lot of problems throughout the entire system, including vandalism, bot abuse,
all sorts of things.
And then, of course, getting the data is hard.
It almost... When you read this, it feels like that the author tries to wrap it up on
a positive note and says, these are all warning signs, and if we take immediate action, maybe
we can save the day.
He calls them roadblocks.
Boy, when I read this, I read this as OpenStreetMaps is screwed.
It seems impossible this day and age.
The data that you need, the proprietary information, the fact that once you build something like
this, people come and vandalize it.
Can OpenSource do this?
Is this just something that OpenSource can't do?
How do we do imaging?
How do we do earth imaging?
Well, go ahead, Whippy.
Wasn't it Whippy?
Oh, whoever it was.
Go ahead.
So OpenStreetMap has been around for a long time.
I remember interviewing someone from the project many years ago on the Ubuntu podcast when
we had little mapping parties because there were just great swathes of emptiness around
our towns and cities in the UK.
They were talking about, maybe by the end of the year, we'll have all of the UK mapped
and there were entire continents that hadn't been mapped yet.
But people came together and they worked together and they fixed those problems.
A lot of these are, you need more bodies.
They need to recruit more people to help moderate the submissions that are happening.
I fixed things.
There was a road that was wrong near me and I just logged in, tried to remember what my
password was, fixed the road, done, and that's fixed for everyone forever who's using that
map.
I think they need a bit more of a recruitment drive to get more people involved in using
it.
They need to make the tools easier to use for sure because it is a little bit janky
to do this and have some incentive for people to moderate these things and make it easier
for people to get access to the data.
If they can solve all those, those are mostly technical but also getting more people involved.
I think they're fine.
I'm more of a glass half full and I know you're quite a glass half empty kind of guy.
But I think this is solvable.
All of this is solvable.
I certainly hope so.
I tend to think that more bodies on the problem is only a part of the issue.
I think some of this is like technology because you think about it, it's a data issue and
the more Google is at a point now where they have millions of Android devices that are
using Google Maps constantly setting real time feedback to Google Maps.
How do you ever come close to anything like that?
You know what I mean?
They talk about their geocoder in here is sort of out of date and I guess you could
somehow, maybe somebody could donate a new geocoder, maybe Nokia could come along or
something like that.
I think that makes it very...
My takeaway from a lot of this is that they need to be clear about what they're trying
to do and not do because it can be hard.
Maybe that's something they can't do but they can still be really valuable as an open database
for all these things even if it's not going to be GMaps level interface.
I mean, technically, they can just use Google Maps data anyway because Google doesn't own
the concept of the data that they collect data around usage, that stuff is they own
but they can't own the map itself.
They don't provide access to the data so the open street map guys can't just poke at Google
and get the data out and they get a cease and desist because some of the data isn't
theirs anyway.
It's licensed from third parties but other people have tried to do, in the same way that
Android devices crowd source a lot of the location and traffic data and so on, other
people have tried this.
Mozilla tried this.
They had a thing that was baked into Firefox OS and actually you could optionally, I think
it was called Mozilla Stumbler, you could install on your phone and just leave it running
in the background and it would just constantly send updates about where Wi-Fi access points
were and try and locate where you were so they can put all these dots on the map and
show where roads are and all that kind of stuff.
It's possible but you need a critical mass of people who are going to do it and obviously
Google with a critical mass of billions of devices are already way out ahead.
I wonder if it isn't a bit of a…
And they also do one thing that I don't know of any voluntary organization or anybody
else doing.
They actually go to governments and ask for maps because governments have dense maps,
infrastructure, detailed, just the data that governments need for defense.
They have it.
All right, fair enough.
It's usually public.
But hopefully, I think that overall, if it's not going to help as much in terms of maps
but in other things, the new GDPR ruling actually goes and says that you as a citizen or as
a customer have the right to ask for the data that is about you but that essentially could
make it easier to compete by you having the ability to export all of your data and importing
a second service.
To Dan's point, like the hours that places are busy, if you could even get a thousand
users to export their hours when they go to stores and import that, that would be useful.
If you could even just get a small fraction…
You just have to be able to get that enabled but enough because they've got it by default.
Yeah.
It still feels a bit like the Spotify problem in that Spotify is attempting to monetize
music streaming when Google, Apple, and Amazon can just do music streaming as part of their
overall offering.
And if it costs them to do music streaming, it doesn't matter because they're selling
you the block into the platform.
And I wonder if that is the same with maps.
It is so expensive and it requires so much overhead to keep good competitive maps that
perhaps it's the vendors that have a platform incentive to have mapping like Google, Apple,
et cetera, that will be the best at it.
And I mean, I hate to keep…
I hate to say this but maybe it's just not our…
Maybe it's not our bag.
Go ahead, JJ.
So I would say like for those who don't want to be dependent on Google services, just those
who root in ROM their devices, they would probably see more incentive into seeing these
open map platforms.
Yes.
And also…
But is that enough?
Is that enough, JJ?
Is that enough?
Because I'll give you an example.
I would like to have an open street map that I could go to where I could get really good
like super specific information about cellular signal.
So I knew where I could go to get really good data signal.
I would like to know where cops often hang out at so I could mark that on a map.
That's something I think that would be extremely useful.
And just for me personally, I'd also like to know where I could park for 24 hours without
getting towed.
And I'd like to mark that up on a map.
And I don't think Google is ever going to do any of that.
I mean, you're partially describing ways there.
Which is owned by Google now.
Yeah.
But still, it's…
But there's still demand for those who want to be free from Google services such as yourself
trying to go away from Google Photos.
There are plenty of people who've built things on top of open street maps like building…
Whether it's making access to data about, like you say, where's parking.
There are people who've built cycle maps.
There are people who've built canal maps in the UK so you know where the canals are.
And it wouldn't take a lot for someone to build on top.
But as you've mentioned, it's difficult getting access to that map data without rebuilding
all the tiles yourself or licensing their API.
So that is a difficult problem.
So I have a question.
Yeah, go ahead.
Would you guys be willing to pay a bounty per se, right?
So you would introduce into the platform a bounty that says, I would like this such region
to be mapped, you know, and this bounty coverage a few kilometers, whatever, right?
And ultimately, then there's people that could attempt to actually map out that thing by
trying to get the winning of that bounty.
And that's a fascinating idea.
That is a really…
As long as you have the moderation to prevent abuse of people just going out and wandering
outside their house for 10 minutes or strapping a phone to a dog and letting it loose in a
field.
What you do is you build an AR game, right?
Yeah, exactly.
I kind of have the sense that maybe I should try to reach out to some folks at the Open
Street Map Project and get their take on this too, because this is Sergey's take, right?
And so I'd like to get their take and see where they…
So if time allows or if anybody out there has a connection, let me know on Telegram
or Twitter.
I'd be more than happy to chat with somebody from the project and get their take on it
and see where they're going with this.
Because like Popeye was saying, there is so many great just esoteric uses that people
have built on top of Open Street Maps, it is worth it just for that to continue.
I mean, I have my crazy reasons, but there's also really good reasons like biking and hiking
and others.
So I would love to talk to somebody there because this is one of those projects where
if there was anything I could do, I'd pay a bounty if there is anything I could do.
If I could run an app on my Android phone while I drive Lady Jups around the country
to help improve their maps, I'd be more than happy to do it.
So if you have anybody out there, if you're listening to this show and you know anybody
out there that maybe I should talk to, I'd love it if you could help make the connection.
Because jeez, if I just don't prefer the way they render the maps, I just prefer reading
Open Street Maps than I do Google Maps.
Not that there's really anything super wrong with Google Maps, I just prefer the way they
look.
They do look really nice.
Yeah.
I like them too.
So you hate to see something like that fade away and it makes you wonder like what other
things?
Like what if one day we all got off our arses and decided we wanted to have an open source
music streaming service?
Could we do it?
Impossible.
What if we wanted to have like a peer-to-peer video streaming service to take on YouTube?
Could we do it?
I'm not convinced we could pull it off.
But Open Street Map is one of those things where we already have a beachhead.
You know, we're-
There's a bunch of data plugged in there.
We already have momentum.
So if there's anything we could do as a community to come together-
Let's not lose that.
Yeah.
Let's keep it going.
Let's keep that rolling.
And I'd love to talk to somebody over there about that.
LinuxAcademy.com slash unplugged.
Go there to sign up for a free seven-day trial and support this here show.
It's everything you need to learn more about Linux.
When I was first starting in IT because IT is like dog years, I don't know if you thought
about this, but I was recently thinking it's kind of like dog years.
Like 10 years in IT is like 25 years in the banking field.
And one of the things that's so crazy about, because I'm just past my mid thirties now,
so it's not like I'm super old, but it is nuts to my face.
It is nuts to my face that when I first got into IT, the way we would look stuff up, I'm
a hundred percent honest with you here, is about once a month a couple of us from the
department would get together in somebody's car and we'd go out to lunch.
And then after lunch, when we're full and may or may not have had a beer in us, we would
go to the bookstore and we would buy a book, a couple of books each.
And then we would bring these books back and we would stack them on the shelf and we would
never use them unless we were really desperate.
Plus you probably got grease on them from the fries from lunch.
You know me too well, Wes.
I couldn't even imagine a resource like Linux Academy and it would have at best been some
sort of half-assed feature that gets added on to some other training platform.
So you know, somewhere for corporate training or learning about active directory management
or how to fix your sync and then they would have thrown on a few Linux courses.
Go learn some more, Chris.
We'll pay you some money to go do that.
And that would have been it.
Later on in my career, what I did have some access to was community college training courses
that would be taught off of campus or on campus, depending on the course, that were about Linux,
but they weren't really about the career track that I was on, but they were just checking
the box.
My employer wanted me to have continued education.
We were deploying Linux servers.
I needed to do something and they wanted results.
So I went and took basic Linux courses like Linux Plus and Introductions to Linux.
Meanwhile I'm sitting there setting up Linux firewalls and Samba servers.
It just didn't match.
That's where Linux Academy completely changes the game, linuxacademy.com slash unplugged.
You sign up for a free seven-day trial.
It's everything you need to learn about any category of Linux from the basics all the
way up to the high level stuff like Azure, AWS, OpenStack, all of that.
They have courses that are also created specifically to help you get certifications if that's the
route you want to go.
They have self-paced in-depth video courses and they have virtual labs they spin up on
demand and if you ever get stuck, they have a real human being that can help you.
It's completely different than anything that I saw many years ago and it's the kind of
tool that's come along now.
Now that Linux has enjoyed some success in the marketplace, somebody had to come along
and create this and I'm so thankful it's Linux Academy because it's created by Linux enthusiasts,
educators, and developers that came together to build the Linux Academy platform and you
can try it out seven days for free at linuxacademy.com slash unplugged, linuxacademy.com slash unplugged.
So you know, I'm going to get into an announcement here, but I just wanted to do an infernal
poll with the mumble room.
If we were going to make a decision today, guys, would you say go back to IRC or stick
with Discord?
It's not related to my announcement at all, but it's something we were talking about,
Wes and I, in the pre-show.
Now that we've been-
Can I cast the first vote?
Yeah, go ahead.
I vote IRC.
Go back to IRC.
Yeah, and I think I can back that up pretty well.
All right, okay.
Let's hear it.
Let's hear it, Mr. Noel.
What is it?
So I think anytime you look at a community, you have to look at the lowest common denominator
to which the community can centralize around and I think in the Linux community, the open
source world, Red Hat organizes their community on IRC and sure there are people that are
organizing on Discord and Telegram.
We've seen when we go to these events, a lot of the abundant people are organizing on Telegram.
So certainly there are other platforms in use, but the lowest common denominator, the
one thing that exists in basically every Linux company and every open source community is
IRC.
And I think that there are some, from a production standpoint, we're tempted to play with some
of the new toys because it looks better on screen, there's more animation.
But I think that that direct community engagement is something that is so valuable, it's worth
giving up anything potentially else just to have that.
All right, so I agree with everything you said.
I'll give you the counter argument.
Discord is born in a mobile era.
You can use Discord in your web browser, you can use Discord on a Windows box, Mac box,
Linux box, you can use Discord on a phone.
Discord is born of a Slack era where you have contextual rich chat with URL previews, image
previews, emoticons, voice chat integrated.
It's how IRC would be designed today if it had access to all of that feature set.
I would agree.
I have all of that.
Go ahead, Poppy.
Mine is voice chat.
I have everything you just said in IRC.
I thought you would be the Discord guy.
Are you serious right now?
I was going to send to you to defend Discord.
If you have the IRC cloud app on your phone, it's in sync with the IRC cloud up on your
desktop.
The only thing missing from the list that you just gave is voice chat.
So what do you think?
Do you think we should go back to IRC for Jupiter broadcasting?
I think you should use Slack.
I would also just piggyback onto that and say that the vast, is there anyone that exists
in the Discord?
Is there anyone that's in that community that doesn't already set up an IRC system?
I think a lot of those people, a lot of people I see in the Discord, they're the same people
that are in IRC.
So they've already set that up.
And yes, I would agree with the gentleman who said that it's a little more difficult
to set up on the phone, and I'm using Quossel, and that also is very simple to set up on
the phone.
Okay.
I'd like to hear from Wimpy and Rotten.
Wimpy, if you're available, just because you've been a longtime observer of JB, you've sat
back, you have some distance from this.
I'd kind of like to hear your thoughts if you're there.
So I'm in the Discord and IRC, but I pay more attention to IRC because the IRC chat is easier
to engage with than Discord chat.
Whenever I go to Discord, there's pages and pages and pages of irrelevant stuff, and I
can drop in and out of IRC.
And as Popey says, I use IRC Cloud as well.
So what I have on my desktop and my mobile phone is the same.
If anyone tags me in any of the channels I'm subscribed to, I get notifications on my phone.
All right.
Okay.
I can't argue with any of that either.
Producer Michael, I wanted to give you...
Oh, Wes, did you want to say something?
I was just saying, does IRC Cloud have a free plan?
I think so.
Yes.
I am also an IRC user.
I would be curious with the opposite number.
I like the comparison idea, but I wonder too how many people have set up IRC just for JB
but already have Discord from other things.
That is a great point.
Okay.
Producer Michael, I wanted to give you a chance, and then maybe I'll come back to you.
They both have problems.
Discord and IRC both have problems.
I mitigate the problems with IRC in the same way, but not with IRC Cloud.
I use Matrix and Riot.im.
Oh, man.
You fancy bear.
You can use Riot.im without actually setting up your own server as well.
You can just use the Matrix.org stuff.
So you are kind of in a roundabout way saying IRC, and if you want the fancy features, there's
ways to get that.
Well, I mean, in the sense of doing the displays and the previews, as far as the communication
aspect, IRC is easier, because a lot of people will say it's harder to set up, but if you're
just brand new to it, you can just go to a Kiwi IRC or something like that where you
just link to someone directly to a thing and they're instantly in the chat.
There's ways to do that where you cannot do that in Discord, and then there's other ways
in, like, if you don't have a Discord account, you can't go to a Discord server, so there
are aspects that, like, the only thing I would say is the previews and the log is not available
directly in IRC.
You'd have to use some way to mitigate that, such as, like, Matrix or IRC Cloud.
Okay.
I am going somewhere with all of this.
This isn't just looking at our navel gazes.
Was that the same navel gaze in here?
I am actually, I am going somewhere with this, but Wimpy, I know you were jumping in there
for a second, so I want to go back to you.
No, Michael's touched on all of those points, really.
I've got nothing extra to add, other than the fact I recently re-added the Jupiter Broadcasting
Channel to my IRC Cloud configuration because I can't submit show title suggestions through
Discord.
Right.
Yeah.
So I'm going to, you know what I'll do is I'll put a poll out there.
It's embedded in the show notes if you want to vote because there's lots of people that
can't make it live that have a position on this that maybe sometimes can that could vote.
What brought this up was the discussion that I was having behind the scenes with Wes just
today about, hey, what if for a hot moment we wanted to see if we could dynamically generate
a live stream video feed on a droplet?
What I mean by that, instead of using OBS here in the studio to capture the chat room,
we had a droplet that was headless that was monitoring a chat room and generating a video
feed and streaming that to Scale Engine.
So I could just connect in with an audio feed from wherever I'm at and the droplet would
actually generate the chat room and the lower third and all of that.
And as that conversation progressed, we realized, well, damn, that's a lot harder when you're
using Discord than it is if you're using IRC.
And especially when it just comes down to stupid things like we have disparate rooms
in Discord for the different shows, which is nice because then it's very focused.
But at the same time, like how do you programmatically plan for that?
Like how do you switch rooms and capture just that and what if the Discord API changes and
what kind of information can we get versus an IRC room where everything's just in one
room and it's text, which is a lot easier to work with server side.
And so then I thought, well, you know, before we go kill ourselves, like what is the interest
here?
Right now, there's only been 19 votes by the live stream.
If you want to vote, strawpoll.me slash 1-5-1-1-5-4-9-6, 68% are voting to go back to IRC.
And I wouldn't shut down Discord, but we would just wait for the live stream focus.
What's up on the live stream?
What do we switch back to?
How does that play into how title stuff is generated?
Is IRC primary more there?
Yeah, I think so.
I think it would mean everything goes back to primary being an IRC.
I don't care either way.
I just want to do whatever folks are happy with.
Although, could we experiment with matrix?
Matrix is interesting.
You can use the IRC with matrix so you can do both of those.
Yeah, that could be something down the road to look more into.
Wow.
Well, actually matrix IRC bridge is fantastic.
I love it.
I use it for so many different channels.
So you're saying go play with that.
Go ahead Noah.
No, I just, that's interesting that this comes up.
This is one of the things that I was kind of dragging my feet on it because I know.
Oh, I know.
This is partially your fault actually.
Well, I heard some rumblings about this and so I was like, ah, just hold off for a little
bit and just see what happens.
But yeah, we were talking about it because one of the things that matrix allows you to
do, and again, this is where I think there's a discussion to be had about software licenses,
right?
Because it's open source, it means that I looked at my team here at UltaSpeed and I
was like, hey, could we do some of these more competitive things from a production standpoint
and tie them in?
They're like, dude, you don't have no idea how easy that would be if we did it with matrix
and we could have these apps and all sorts of crazy things were coming up.
And so I'd be tempted if you guys did decide to dig into that, I'd dig into it with you
and handle some of the heavy lifting because I know how much you love dealing with the
minutia of the projects, Chris.
You do.
Yeah.
Wes has got some great ideas too.
We should, we really all need to get together and do a little powwow.
I completely agree.
All right.
Well.
I've been using matrix with IRC for Intergos, IRC for channel for years now.
Huh.
All right.
Don't convince me, Michael.
I'm going to, I'm going to spend a little more time and consideration with that.
Okay.
So I've got a big announcement that I'm pretty excited about that I want to get into, but
before I do, I don't know.
I wanted to make a little space here for Mr. Popey and Mr. Wimpy.
Perhaps they would like to pre-tease some announcement.
I know Curry just recently happened.
The Ubuntu podcast has been on season break.
Rumor has it the band may be getting back together.
Yeah.
So.
That's it.
No, go ahead.
Maybe.
So yeah, we, for those who don't know, like Wimpy and I do this little podcast.
It's a little two bit show with.
It's a wonderful show.
Everybody should be listening.
Thanks.
Ubuntu podcast.
Thank you.
And every year since we started 10 years ago, we stop recording at Christmas that we make
our last episode goes out over Christmas and then we take a break for a couple of months
so we can all have a rest.
And then we have a traditional go out for a curry and then at that curry we decide whether
we're going to do it for another year and our plans for what we will change and what
will stay the same.
And we make loads of notes and we implement changes in the following week or so.
And then we start the new season sometime soon after that.
Isn't that right Wimpy?
That's about it, right?
Yes.
Roughly like that.
Yeah.
Can I ask you a question about that though?
Okay.
How many years have you done the show where after the curry you didn't return?
But you never know.
So far we have a hundred percent success rate of coming back after having a curry.
But one year.
Here's my suggestion.
One year.
Why not?
But I have a suggestion for you Wimpy.
How about at the last episode of recording you just do it at the curry place and then
go ahead and decide right then.
That's adorable.
We've got to have a break.
It's pretty intense.
It's really hard work.
You can have a break.
You can still make a decision and then take a break as well.
Yeah maybe.
Doing one half hour show.
Listen.
Producer Michael you wouldn't understand this but doing one half hour show a week or recording
two of them every two weeks is a huge amount of work.
Also you're suggesting we have curry at Christmas.
Are you mad?
Yeah.
Speaking of curry.
All seasons.
I was just going to say I'd like to lodge a complaint with my boss at Jupiter Broadcasting.
Why is it we never have any sort of discussions around curry?
Oh I don't ever remember being invited to curry to discuss the next iteration of Vast
Noah or Lass.
I know dude.
It's not just this.
There's another.
This and another.
I am taking two lessons from the Ubuntu podcast and I will be integrating them into the announcement
that I have coming up in mere moments.
Really.
I'm taking lessons.
I'm taking notes.
But yeah guys.
It's good to know that we're so influential.
I'm looking forward to it.
But I do also want to give a mention to our buddies over at Late Night Linux.
Episode 31 of Late Night Linux, they had Todd the CEO of Purism on to talk about a lot of
the questions that I raised on Linux Action News and that Joe's been wondering.
And the guys over there just did a great job of asking Todd the questions and Todd did
a great job of answering them.
So if you've been following the Librem 5 or if you've followed my journey with some of
their stuff, I want to just totally give you a recommendation here.
Go check out episode 31.
I had a fantastic interview with the CEO of Purism about a lot of the things that have
been on many of our minds.
So that's episode 31 of Late Night Linux.
Ubuntu podcast could be coming up, but I'm going to beat all of them with my new release.
I'm very, very happy to announce the return of an old favorite to the Jupiter Broadcasting
Network for a limited time.
I'm doing something kind of different here and I think it's going to be fun.
It's just to the lead up and just a little bit after scale for a limited time, I'm bringing
back Tech Talk Today to the Jupiter Broadcasting Network and you can go over to techtalk.today.
Now I know what you're thinking.
Why Tech Talk Today?
Why do Tech Talk Today when you could relaunch Plan B or come up with some other Linux only
show?
It's a good question.
You know, we put Tech Talk Today on hiatus in September of 2016 so we could launch UserAir.
And I thought surely somebody will come along, like that Joe Resington asshole or Tom Merritt,
and they'll launch another tech show.
You know what?
They're bastards, aren't they?
Those bastards.
You know.
I sure do.
They'll launch another tech show that finally gives a perspective that's outside the Silicon
Valley bubble, that maybe even by some weird luck, somebody on the show has used open source
software once in their life or knows that they're using open source software.
Surely by 2018, such a hero shall come along.
And yet no such Batman has arrived on the scene and it's always really bothered me.
I've gotten on the soapbox more than a few occasions about tech journalism on this show.
There's lots of good tech shows.
There really are.
There's too many.
There's too many tech shows.
But they all have a really strong Silicon Valley bias.
They typically can't see beyond the apps on their smartphone, to be honest with you.
And it drives me crazy.
So looking at the near term future of Jupiter broadcasting, we definitely have a content
problem.
I'm going to be traveling to scale.
We're going to have Linux Fest Northwest.
And if things continue in the direction that they're going, I'll have more interviews
at company like Microsoft and others that don't really fit into Linux Unplugged.
They don't fit into LAM.
They don't fit into Coder.
So I'm going to launch a limited run of Tech Talk today.
Something new, just one season.
In fact, I'm doing seasons.
That's one of the-
Whoa.
Yeah.
I'm stealing that from Open2Podcast.
And they invented it and I'm taking it.
I'm doing seasons and I'm going to do 10 episodes a season.
So I'm just doing 10 episodes and I really would like you to give it a listen because
I'm going to use this as an opportunity to have a fun romp.
Really just, what did you call it?
Self-referential tech coverage.
What did you say earlier?
It was almost like it could have been a tagline.
Something you liked about Tech Talk today was the fact that it didn't take itself too
seriously.
Exactly.
It's a good fun show.
I can't remember the words you used, but I should have written them down.
And that's what our goal is.
We'll have some curry later and we'll think about that.
But because I'm doing a season, I'm going to have a bit of a story arc to it.
It's really going to be about getting my butt down to scale.
And Noah and I specifically are going in with some things that we want to accomplish, some
objectives ahead of time.
And some of-
Like eating curry?
Yeah.
Yes, absolutely.
That'll be in there as well.
So I'm relaunching a show for a limited run.
It's just going to be a lot of fun.
I'm going to experiment with some stuff and we're going to talk lifestyle stuff, culture
stuff, tech news with somebody that comes with the perspective of the open source community.
So if there's something in there from our perspective, I'm covering it.
That'll be the stuff that gets preferential treatment.
It's going to be a fun experiment.
And I may try doing a few things in there that you don't expect.
So check it out.
I would love to have you subscribe.
The raw dog RSS feed, plug it into whatever you want, tech talk today or tech talk dot
today slash RSS, tech talk dot today slash RSS.
There is going to be some exclusive content I'll generate for our patrons too at the Jupiter
signal Patreon page.
Working with seasons sounds interesting.
What do you think of that?
Is that crazy?
No, I think I think it makes a lot of sense.
10 episodes.
Can I ask you a question?
Yeah, go ahead.
Is this something that you're doing live or is this something that it will be recorded
offline then just published?
So a bit of both because predominantly I'm going to be all over the place during these
next 10 episodes.
Some of it's going to just have to be offline.
In fact, I think the majority of it will be offline.
There won't even be a YouTube video of it because it's just going to be Chris on the
road talking about whatever I'm doing, talking about the news of the day, talking about the
events we're going to.
It's going to be kind of raw.
I really like that.
Yeah, I think that's going to be like tech vlog today.
Yeah, it's going to be kind of a little bit actually a little bit like tech vlog today.
It's mostly drone reviews to be honest.
But honestly, I think there's also the perfect opportunity to then have like special live
events because if we're not doing a live one all the time, like when we do a live one and
I'd like to at least do a couple of season, then that's kind of like a special event and
we'll make a special event out of it.
So I do plan to do some live stuff.
But I honestly suspect when Noah was here, he and I worked to install a microphone mount
in my truck.
I expect I'll be doing a lot of the tech talk today's from the passenger seat of my truck
while I'm going to do something.
I'm going somewhere.
I'm on my way to scale.
I'm going to an interview.
I'm going to wake up in the morning.
I'm going to look at the tech news.
I'm going to think about stuff.
I'm going to jump in the car.
I'll either go park somewhere and do a show or I'll have somebody else driving and I'm
going to sit down and I'm going to record an episode.
Now that's not to say it's going to sound like shit because you guys know I'm not going
to put something out that sounds like crap.
So I'm going to also work on that.
This will be another way for me behind the scenes to really kind of iron out the remote
recording setup and whatnot, really get some of that stuff dialed in.
Then we'll be documenting the journey to scale and kind of what that's been like.
So that'll be where some of the vlog element comes in.
Some of the people I talk to, some of the events people would get to bump into, I'll
be in there.
So I think it's going to be a particular kind of new show at JB, even though it's an old
show at the same time.
Can I ask a question, Chris?
Yes.
Will you be changing the show artwork or will you be keeping the thing where you've got
the jacket and the shorts and your weird feet stance?
I know the feet do look weird.
I was just looking at the feet and I'm not quite sure what happened with the feet.
I don't really know.
Because, Wes, I mean, look, my feet aren't, my feet's not that, it's not that weird.
Totally normal.
Normal foot.
I mean, there's the extra things, but we don't have to get into that.
Yeah, it's just webbing.
So what I plan to do is implement a chest up approach to the artwork because it's the
weird feet, right?
Although then at the same time, I kind of like, I kind of like it.
It's kind of like Noah's dick in his AltaSpeed logo.
It's sort of, you remember the weird feet, you know?
So I learned from Noah, the savvy businessman that he is.
You know what?
People talk about my, we're having a conversation about AltaSpeed and I didn't buy, I didn't
buy AdSpot on Linux Unplugged.
That's right.
Exactly.
But, Poby, if you have, if you have any artwork that you want to mock up for me, I'd, I'd,
I'm the last person on the job.
Maybe we can make it just the feet.
That might be what we need to do.
There you go.
Yeah, man.
So scale March 8th through the 11th.
I know I'm just excited about it.
I'm curious to see where they go with this thing.
You know, it's been going in a certain direction that I wasn't super into and now they've
righted the ship and they seem to be sailing in a new direction.
So I'm curious to go see that.
But more importantly, it's like, well, where the hell are things going?
Really?
You've got, you got that crazy canonical shipping gnome.
You got elementary OS encrypting their drives.
You got containers for days.
You've got all these different interests that have kind of really established their places
now.
Where's all of this going, especially just in the next, I don't know, 10 months, where's
this all going for Linux and open source.
And those are some of the things that I want to try to answer over the next few weeks on
tech talk today and on this show.
And I believe that Noah and I will be on the same beat.
So you'll hear more about on ask Noah as well.
I think it's going to be really kind of a fun experiment.
And the best part about it is only 10 episodes, right?
Like, it's just like a go for it and then like, you get in, you get out.
Yeah.
Like I just, I've never done anything.
I'm just going to do 10 of them and then I'm going to go have curry.
I think that's brilliant.
What do you think, Noah?
Is that, is that crazy?
I think there's one crucial part of that missing, but you really like, so when you look at the
way that you want to do that, I think the important thing is to craft is to get input
from outside sources.
And I think the best way to do that is to invite me along for the curry.
And other than that, I think it's a good plan.
And maybe sometimes do a weekly show with our mumble room guys.
Thank you for making it.
I really appreciate it.
It was a good show with you.
Stick around because the ask Noah program's coming up.
If you didn't know the ask Noah show just moments away and you you can hang out here
and join him otherwise join us live.
We do this at 2 PM Pacific.
The live show usually kicks off around 1 31 45 Pacific and all of that is converted to
the proper time in your local area at Jupiter broadcasting.com slash calendar and find the
tech talk today program, the relaunch at tech talk.today and it's tech talk.today slash
RSS for the feed.
Give it a listen.
Let me know what you think.
We have some special stuff in the works and uh, I don't know.
It's fun to bring it back.
It's fun to bring back people.
You know, people are still subscribed to that show.
People are still downloading that show.
It's still got a subreddit like it just, it needs to come back for even just a bit.
Tech talk yesterday.
Tech talk yesterday tomorrow at tech talk.today.
Go check it out and then find the calendar for the live shows, our contact page at Jupiter
broadcasting.com and we also have the subreddit linuxunplugged.letit.com and we got all the
things.
We got all the things.
No excuse not to reach out.
You got the ask Noah show coming up and you can come over here on the Tuesdays and just
hang out for a nice old Linux meal.
You get the unplugged program, which is a really nice long live stream.
Then you get the ask Noah show.
It's a good Tuesday afternoon.
Yeah, we had a long winded discussion that didn't really answer your questions.
Just just ask Noah.
Just ask Noah.
And then once you're done listening to all this live stuff, go check out techsnap.systems
for Wes and I talking about system administration and network building woes and the Ubuntu podcast
as well.
And go check out Tux Digital on YouTube because producer Michael is putting out stuff over
there.
All right.
That concludes the plugs of this week's episode.
You know every now and then you got to get them out.
You got to get them out.
Props.
It's like it's like a form of therapy.
Just got to get it out.
Thank you for joining us, guys.
Hope you and gals.
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Go follow me.
I'm at Chris LAS on the Twitter.
We're talking about some of our projects.
The network's at Jupiter signal.
That guy right there.
He's at West Payne.
That's right.
I like that.
Damn.
That's almost as good as bacon, dude.
So good.
It might be.
I would like to see Payne versus bacon to see which one wins.
Don't forget.
While we're voting, we have the poll in the show notes.
Should we go back to IRC or stay on Discord for the live chat and the focus of the show?
You decide.
Let us know.
You can vote.
We'll see you in the next one.
You don't need to install that.
Don't bother.
Don't bother yourself.
You got other things to do.
Haven't you heard of OS?
It's just the primary platform for your tools.
All right, JBtitles.com, title suggestions.
What do you guys think?
What should we do?
What should we do, JBtitles.com?
Make IRC great again.
Metrics talk today.
That is a pretty clever combo.
You came out there with tech nav.
Tech nav.
All right, so you all have to go over and subscribe and listen to Tech Talk today at
least for one or two episodes and then let me know what you think.
You got to give it like a two episode go because it's going to take me a little bit to find
a groove.
So go over there and give it a two episode go for me.
Should it be a new RSS feed or use the old one?
Well, it was going to use the old one and then there was a bit of a server failure on
my part and as of right now, it's tech talk today.
It's tech talk dot today slash RSS.
The old feed may start working again and it may not.
If you're lucky.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
One ping only was my title suggestion in reference to the canonical data collection.
Which I thought was kind of good because, you know.
I mean, after today, I'm sort of like interested in trying to get one of these either matrix
or riot to work with IRC.
There you go.
I'm still trying to figure out how.
You maniac.
So one ping only is, of course, I submitted that so I'm a little particular.
I like that and the metrics talk today is nice.
One ping only is elegant.
I like that part a lot.
And it also sort of reinforces the point that it's just one really kind of big data shot.
But yeah, I don't know.
That's my thought.
I don't really have a strong sense.
I would like to see them publish that data.
I would really like to see that data.
Yeah.
I wonder what the granularity will be.
Down to OEMs.
That's all really what I'd be happy for.
It's funny.
Having that Apple thing go automatic, like when that Apple pop-up first landed in Ubuntu,
people complained and said Ubuntu was more crashy than previous releases.
And that's because previous releases didn't have a pop-up that told you something was
crashy.
And now it does, right?
And so there are so many blog posts out there that tell you how to turn that thing off and
make Apple go away.
And it's so frustrating for me when I'm looking at the errors website and looking at all the
crashes and thinking, what are the crashes that we're not capturing?
Because people turn that thing off.
And so that's why I'm keen for that thing to be fully automatic.
So if people tick the box, they just get sent.
And then we can look at the crash log, crash dumps, and we can fix them.
Yep.
I agree.
Because I actually almost always just dismiss it because I don't want to go through because
I've had enough of those ask me then to log in or provide an email address or things like
that.
And so I just clear it.
I clear it immediately as soon as I see it.
Because I'm just trying to get something relaunched and get back on air.
But yeah, I agree.
I would be more than happy to just send in the background and not bother me and let me
get about my day.